One of the most important aspects of network security for any organization is to protect
against attacks and one of the most important aspects of network security for any organization is
to protect against attacks and if you hear the news and everything else these days, network
attacks are something that every organization has to worry about but also protect against and so
that becomes the focus, large focus of any network security program of any organization. Now we
could spend weeks talking about the different types of attacks that are possible out there, there
are so many. We are only going to focus on the ones that you might see on the exam that we know are
there and that the CISSP common body of knowledge obviously addresses. We're going to start with
what are called IP based attacks and these are attacks that operate at layer 3 because as you know,
IP is a TCP IP protocol that operates at the network layer and because of that we remember saying
something like IP is like the captain of the team, it is what drives a lot of what the other
protocols and layers need to do in order to allow communications to happen. So there's a lot of
attacks that can happen here and we're going to focus on some of the important ones. The ones that
you see on your screen, the ones on both ends, the overlapping fragment attack and the tear drop
fragment attack are all fragmentation attacks. If you remember to what IP is responsible for, there are
really two major things that IP and the network layer needs to be able to do. Those two things are
fragmentation and addressing and so the attacks that you typically find here are against those two
functionalities, fragmentation and the addressing part. So both of these, the overlapping fragment
attack and the tear drop fragment attack result in denial of service. That's what you need to remember
about these two. We don't have to get into the details of them but just understand that they are
denial of service attacks that lead to denial of service. The denial of service simply means
any attack that tries to bring down the ability of a system or an architecture or an application
or something to do what it's supposed to. So those are denial service attacks. Now the one
that you see in the middle, IP spoofing. On its own simply means to spoof an IP address. Spoofing
means to pretend to be something else, usually because that something else is more authorized
than you are. So you try and spoof IP addresses or MAC addresses or user IDs or an email address
because that other thing is more authorized than you are. That's simply what we mean by spoofing.
Here specifically this is IP spoofing. So you are spoofing a IP address to look like you are
legitimate but it is the basis. IP spoofing is the basis for two very important attacks that
you might see again and they are spurf and fraggle. Now both of these sound cute but they're
really not that cute if you experience them. And again both of these you need to remember
are denial of service attacks as well but they both require IP spoofing first and then if you flood
the host with ICMP echo packets that's what the smurf attack does. So the smurf attack basically
is IP spoofing and then we flood the host with ICMP echo requests which ultimately will bring
that host down causing the denial of service condition. Now most organizations are actually not
prone to the smurf attack and here's why it's pretty standard for most organizations to block
incoming ICMP packets because ICMP is also the basis for two very important commands out there
that can provide very useful information to potential attackers and those two commands are
ping and trace route and if you know anything about those two commands ping tries to see if a host
is reachable if it's alive if it's operating system if it's operating that might be way too much
information that you want to give out to potential attackers out on the web. And so the other
command that also uses ICMP is trace route and that's even more dangerous because it tries to map
what your network elements actually look like which again can be pretty useful to an attacker
that's sitting out there and that's why it's pretty standard for all organizations out there to
block incoming ICMP traffic right at the firewall so that you don't let potential attackers out on the
web ping and trace route what our network elements and hosts look like so it's pretty standard
to block that and that's why this attack the smurf attack because it uses ICMP packets isn't really
meaningful for most organizations but attackers are pretty crafty individuals they've devised a
similar attack called fraggle which just like smurf uses IP spoofing as the basis for the attack
first but then instead of flooding the host with ICMP packets we flood the host with UDP packets
and nobody out there blocks incoming UDP because UDP is too valuable for a lot of things related to
streaming voice over IP DNS requests and so on so that's a pretty meaningful attack that you
need to protect against but very difficult to do that all right so as a summary we've talked about
the two denali service attacks called smurf and fraggle and they both require IP spoofing
as the basis for the attack and then we flood the host that's how both attacks work and you need
to remember that they both result in denali service attacks and in fact the next slide here talks
about the two types of denali service attacks as categories that exist out there and I think you've
heard of these we have what's called denali service which really means any attack that tries to
bring down the ability of something to do what it's supposed to that is referred to as a general
category of attacks called denali service now distributed denali service attacks is where we
compromise a whole bunch of hosts and then get each one of them to attack a specific other host
the idea is if you want to bring down that host you may not be able to do it yourself because
you don't have enough bandwidth or processing power to be able to do it so what you need to do
first is solicit help from a whole bunch of other machines out there in other words you compromise
all of those machines and then you get each one of them to attack that machine that you want to
bring down at the same time it's a distributed denali service it has a whole bunch of zombies
sometimes these are referred to as zombie attacks because you are using those machines as an
attacker you're using those machines that you've compromised to attack a specific other one
that's why we referred to those sometimes as zombie attacks but they're distributed denali service
attacks now you need to remember that a distributed denali service attack is actually a category of
denali service the overall category is called denali service of which distributed denali service
is one example of and so here's another attack that we need to worry about again in this entire
section we're focusing on some of the most prevalent attacks that exist out there that we from a
security perspective need to protect against as part of network security one of them is what we
call the man in the middle attack so any person that can sit in the middle of two things that are
trying to communicate with each other is referred to as a man in the middle attack so in this
example we can intercept we can lead to denali service anything that can originate usually outside
on the internet can be considered to be a denali service attack or a man in the middle attack because
again the internet and the web is typically in the middle of all other networks that companies
have set up so any attack that originates out on the internet or the web can be considered to be
a man in the middle attack and if you think about it that way it'll be easy from an example
perspective the easiest attack that a man in the middle can perform is usually a denali service
attack because that typically originates from the web and impacts organizations out there
another attack that we need to be weary of and protect against is what we call spoofing now
I know we've talked about that term spoofing many times it simply means to pretend to be something
else or someone else because that's something or someone else typically has more privileges or
capabilities and so what can you spoof we can spoof IP addresses we can spoof MAC addresses we
can also spoof DNS servers or email that belongs to someone else again you're trying to pretend to
be something else because that's something else typically has more privileges than you do that we
referred to as spoofing sometimes also referred to as masquerading and these are some of the tools
that are available for attackers to try and figure out information that may lead to potential
attacks because if you think about any attack the first phase in any potential attack is always
what we call reconnaissance reconnaissance means you know the initial gathering of information about
a potential target that would allow us to ultimately attack that target from any network attack
perspective and so some of these tools like ping and trace route can be very useful to attackers
because they can gain some very useful information that ultimately will allow them to be successful
in their attacks now we've already talked about how ping and trace route the basis for both of
those attacks is ICMP so it's pretty standard for most organizations to block incoming ICMP which
renders these two commands and possibilities useless from an attack perspective if you block
incoming ICMP now DHCP is another one of those TCP IP protocols that sometimes are problematic
we all experience this DHCP is a protocol that automatically assigns you a valid IP address
in the range that's been allocated for a specific network so when you check into a hotel or you go
to Starbucks or you go anywhere where there's a network available a Wi-Fi network available
as soon as you connect to that network it is DHCP that's part of TCP IP that assigns you a valid
IP address now that seems very useful but it's also very useful to attackers because at that point
they become typically a trusted entity on the network and in many cases that's all the network
requires to trust that device from a network security perspective what we want to do is we want
to allow DHCP to assign a valid IP address but what should happen after that is authentication
of not only the device that's just connected but also the person that's sitting behind that device
in other words it's really important if you're going to allow DHCP to assign valid IP addresses
to subsequently authenticate the device that's connecting which is called node authentication
but then we also need to know who is sitting behind that node and that's where we do user authentication
so across a network it's really important to address authentication at two levels the node
authentication which means we can authenticate based on things like MAC address or IP address
but then we have to authenticate the person sitting behind that node and that's where we use
access control to authenticate the person by using the three factors that you're aware of
authentication by knowledge ownership and characteristics or a combination of all of those
now here's another example of an attack that is very prevalent and it's called ARP poisoning
we've already talked about ARP and what ARP does ARP is it maps IP addresses to the correct MAC
addresses and this is required on any network because the logical addressing that is used across
any network is called IP addressing and that is something that happens at the network layer
so if you want to connect to a server out there or if you want to send an email ultimately the way
that that information is actually transmitted and connected to the receiver is through the logical
addressing that happens across networks which is what we call IP addressing but as a request comes
in to your internal network it has to take that IP address and it has to be mapped to the correct
MAC address which is what makes every single device across a network unique it's your physical
address that makes you unique on any network that is something that is referenced as a MAC address
at the data link layer so what the network needs to do is it needs to take that IP address
and map it to the correct MAC address as a request comes in to the internal network
and the protocol that does that is actually called ARP now the way that ARP works is that every
device that's connected to a network will have its own ARP table that allows these resolutions to
be made the idea is when a router handles that datagram that's coming into the network it will
broadcast out to the entire segment and say okay who belongs to this and based on the information
that's in your ARP table you would say it's me and so therefore the router would send that
information to you based on the information that's in your ARP table now here's how easy it is
for an attacker to influence this so that the wrong decision is made so if I'm an attacker on a
segment and I want to pretend to be some other device all I need to do is change my own ARP table
to point to some other device and then any information meant for that device will be sent to me
because of that entry that I've put in my own ARP table so when the router broadcasts out and says
who belongs to this I'm gonna say it's me because I've put in that entry in my own ARP table
so then the router will send that information to me as opposed to the real device I can look at
that information I can change it and then I can route it back and that device would never know
this is how easy it is to perform ARP poisoning and so this is pretty difficult to handle as
something that can happen across any segment of a network and the slide that you see in front of
you basically describes how that attacker can influence the wrong decisions that are being made
by ARP because ARP uses tables and anything that uses tables typically does not require security
to be able to make decisions and so ARP is not the only protocol out there and service out there
that is influenced by the wrong decisions anything that uses tables is typically prone to the same
problem ARP is one example routers use tables to make decisions they can be influenced in much
the same way DNS uses tables to make decisions they can be influenced in much the same way switches
use tables these devices and protocols all have basically the same problem as ARP poisoning
that we just described here